MALE SPEAKER: Today we
have the pleasure of having
Marc Goodman here with us.
Marc Goodman has spent a
career in law enforcement
and technology.
He has served as a street
police officer, senior advisor
to Interpol, and futurist
in residence at the FBI.
As the founder of the
Future Crimes Institute
and the chair for
policy, law and ethics
at Silicon Valley's
Singularity University,
he continues to investigate
the intriguing and often
terrifying intersection
of science and security,
uncovering nascent
threats and combating
the darker sides of technology.
Let's give a warm
welcome to Marc Goodman.
MARC GOODMAN:
Thanks [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you very much.
Hi Google.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MARC GOODMAN: Hey,
how you guys doing?
Thanks so much for coming,
I really appreciate it.
We need to also be thinking
about the internet of things,
right, because we're going to
be attaching a lot more things
to the internet.
So it's not just the
internet of things,
it's just more
crap to be hacked.
We're switching
from IPv4 to IPv6,
that will mean that our
network will grow from about 4
and a half billion simultaneous
connections to 78 octillion,
or 78 billion billion billion.
To put it in perspective,
today's internet
is the size of a golf
ball, tomorrow's will
be the size of the sun.
That means every pet, plate,
prisoner, knife, fork, chair,
every device will be going
online with RFID and near field
communication, because
they'll basically be free.
Our threat surface area is
going to expand tremendously.
And guess who's
excited about this?
General Petraeus of the CIA.
Right, we will spy on you
through your dishwasher.
And you guys heard about
this Samsung brouhaha?
Where Samsung-- who
hasn't heard of this?
So right now, I have a
smart television at home.
But in order to
change the channel,
I have to push a
button while I sit
my fat ass in a
Barcalounger and might
burn a billionth of a calorie.
So Samsung has
solved this problem
by allowing for voice
interactive TVs.
But in order to
do that, they had
to update their terms
of service and say,
everything you say
to your television
we're sending out
to third parties.
We're processing it, we
keep it, and the like.
It's in part of their
terms of service.
And then they said,
Samsung did, by the way,
if there's something
sensitive you
want to discuss
in your own home,
don't say it in front
of the television
because we're listening.
Which didn't make
people very happy,
so there's a big
brouhaha about this.
"New York Times" talked
about hacking everything
from vents to soda machines.
And do you guys remember
that Target hack?
You remember how they got in?
Through the air conditioning.
Yeah, the HVAC system.
The HVAC was connected to
the general network which
was connected to financial
management which was connected
to the cash register
which was connected
to the point of sale terminals.
When you have 78
octillion connections,
the system complexities
are so great.
You have no idea what's
connected to what.
And bad guys are good
at finding this out.
Of course, refrigerators
will be sending spam.
This has already happened.
This is already
happening, right?
Oh, and by the way, this has
happened too, I'm sorry to say.
So a lot of apps now have
bitcoin mining malware in them.
This is from the
Department of Things
Not to Connect to the Internet.
In Florida, they thought
they'd save money
by connecting their prisons
throughout the state online.
It turns out, somebody
hacked them and they unlocked
all the doors at a maximum
security prison in Miami,
leading to a riot.
Of course, cars are nothing
more than computers on wheels,
right?
200 chips.
And people have
hacked those, there
was a guy in Austin, Texas that
remotely disabled 100 cars.
Everything from the air bag
to the brakes to the steering
can be hacked.
And of course, we're
putting computers,
we're not just
writing computers,
but we're computers
inside ourselves.
There are 60,000 pacemakers
in the United States
and have an IP address and
connect to the network.
300,000 implantable
medical devices a year.
At hacker conferences
like Black Hat and DEFCON
they're talking about
how to hack them.
Diabetic pumps.
This is something called
the Bluetooth Cannon.
From a distance of
300 feet, it can
find people that have
got diabetic pumps
and take 45 days
worth of insulin
and release it in five minutes.
Resulting in a
condition known as--
AUDIENCE: Death.
MARC GOODMAN: That's very good.
Mostly irreversible,
very hard to change.
This is my friend Bertolt Meyer.
He was born without a left hand.
He has one of the most
advanced bionic arms and hands
in the world.
I said, Bertolt tell
me how do you control
your arm if you need to fix it.
He was like, oh, I have
an app on my iPhone
that controls my hand.
I said cool, can
I see your phone?
He hands me his phone,
I start pushing buttons,
his hand starts doing this.
His body is online.
By the way, I didn't
need to have the phone
because it's Bluetooth.
I could have just used
Blue Snarf or anything else
to hack it.
So again, our threat
surface area is expanding.
And it's not just
today's technologies
with ones and zeros, but
there are other technologies.
All the stuff we've
been talking today,
they've been hacking silicon.
But there was another operating
system, the original operating
system, DNA.
We only coded in ones
and zeroes because we
didn't understand DNA.
Now we do.
We can write
software code in DNA.
There are bio hackers.
And you can take
somebody else's DNA
that you recover from a left
tissue or a comb or a drinking
glass and replicate it.
And you can take that DNA and
leave it at a crime scene.
And according to a study, the
cops can't tell the difference.
So if you really really hate the
guy in the cubicle next to you,
this is a fun trick
to play on them.
Plant their DNA at
the scene of a crime.
And of course we will
have new bio weapons
that will be permitted
through synthetic biology.
Aum Shinrikyo, you guys remember
them, subway attack in Tokyo?
These guys had a bio program.
They had $10 million that
they spent from '85 to '95
trying to launch a bio attack.
The biology wasn't
there, so they
went with a chemical attack.
Today it is.
And so we're going to have
all of these new issues
to deal with, ranging from
cloning to discrimination
to new forms of identity theft.
If you find any this bio
hacking stuff interesting,
I did an article for
"Wired" magazine.
That's my ugly mug on
the / so every crime
that we have today with
silicon ones and zeroes,
we will have in the
future with bio.
What's the bottom line?
With all of this computing,
going golf ball to sun,
we're increasingly connected.
We're dependent upon these
systems, and we're vulnerable.
Computers run all our
critical infrastructures,
from electricity to
health care to 911 system.
And they're all hackable.
There's never been
built a computer
system that couldn't be hacked.
And we keep rushing, connecting
more and more stuff to the net,
but more connections
equals more vulnerability.
So what do we do?
I'm not saying
technology is bad, right?
I'm in Silicon Valley.
I love tech.
Tech is awesome.
Fire was the first technology.
It could keep you warm at night.
It could cook food
in your cave, or you
could use it to burn down
the village next to yours.
It's just how we're using it.
But make no mistake,
there is a war afoot
between people that want
to use tech for good
and people that want
to use tech for evil.
And in exponential times,
the ability of one person
to reach out to 100
million or a billion people
is a growing problem
that we haven't
solved how to handle yet.
When the entire world
is becoming a computer,
Marc Andreessen famously said
software is eating the world.
When maps become GPS
devices, when music becomes
Spotify and Netflix is movies.
Every physical object
is becoming a computer.
And all computers
are run by code.
So if you can control the
code, in a world where
computers run the world, then
you can control the world.
And the biggest problem
is, unlike other times,
most people have no idea
that they're a victim.
If you go out your garage in the
morning and look for your car
and it's missing, you're like,
holy cow, my car was stolen.
But when bad guys break into
your computer, you don't know.
According to a study by the
US Secret Service and Verizon,
only 6% of hacks
of data breaches
are picked up by the
system administrator.
94% of the time, it's
because customers complain,
the FBI comes knocking
at their door,
or a competitor was also hacked.
And this is a really
scary statistic.
This is the time to discovery.
On average, it takes an American
Fortune 500 company 211 days
to know that they're penetrated.
Which means that
the bad guys are
living in your system
for nearly seven months,
roaming around,
putting in back doors,
leaving malware,
watching and studying
everything that you're doing.
And in the same study,
they said that 75%
of American
corporations networks
could be penetrated
in just 15 minutes.
So breaking into the information
technologies of today
is a lot like a hot knife
going through butter.
It's super easy.
And yet all of these
computers are the foundations
of our modern world.
So when they fail,
when they're hacked,
when that cyber crisis occurs,
what is our backup plan?
We don't have one.
In effect, our modern
society's is kind of
built on a digital
house of cards
that can come falling down
unless we start to care for.
This is how we handle
cyber threats today.
We arrest people.
The problem is that NYPD officer
cannot make an address right,
in Moscow, or in Canada.
Internet broke policing.
Policing only works city to
city, country to country.
International law is
horrible for these types
of investigations,
and therefore we
will never investigate or arrest
our way out of the cyber threat
problem.
The two systems are
completely mismatched,
and yet this is the
primary tool we use today.
Right, the cops,
we're in charge.
We're going to handle this.
We need to break that
paradigm of policing.
We need to get the
public involved.
The bad guys have been really
good at crowd sourcing offense.
We need to get crowd sourcing
on defense on our own security.
There are some great
examples of that.
This was highlighted at
Google Ideas, organized crime
and corruption project.
These guys are crowd
sourcing the investigation
of dictators and their funds.
And in Mexico, where
over 50,000 narcotics
related homicides have
occurred in the past six years,
people are using
tools like Google Maps
to go out there and
crowdsource where
the dope dealers are at great
personal risk to themselves.
So open source tools like
this, free tools like this,
can play a role in helping us
to crowdsource our own security.
But I think we're going to
need to take it a step further.
We have reserve Marines, reserve
Army, reserve police officers.
We have FEMA for
national disasters.
We have no national
cybersecurity reserve corps.
And we're definitely
going to need one.
And folks in this room
are the exact type
of people that I would
recruited into it, because we're
going to need your help.
Because that big cyber
emergency is going to occur,
and we have no plan
for when it does.
The other thing I
would offer is that we
talk about cyber attacks.
We use the language of medicine.
We talk about
computer infections.
We talk about viruses.
We use the language of medicine
to describe the problem.
But we don't use the tools of
medicine to solve the problem.
What could epidemiology
bring to the table, right?
What would a World Health
Organization for cyber
look like?
Public health models,
epidemiological models I think
could go a long way
in terms of helping
to protect the internet.
And by the way, what could
we learn from bio-mimicry?
Right, nature for
four billion years
has been building immune
system's, resilient systems.
How could we learn
from biology and nature
to drive this forward?
Another big challenge is
human centered design.
Anybody every use like a
Norton Utilities product.
When my mom uses her
software firewall,
it says warning, error, MSCX
DL3 DLL error at line code this.
Do you wish to proceed?
That is not helpful to my mom.
It's not helpful to me.
OK, think about all
the beautiful products
we have in the world.
A Leica camera, a Porsche 911.
Whatever those
beautiful things are,
where's the Johnny
Ives of security?
The guy that's going to design
the most beautiful, human
centered design for security.
We don't have that.
And so because of
poor engineering
and a lack of designed
thinking, we're
driving people to make
poor security decisions.
We need to fix that.
And I also think that
we need a Manhattan
Project for cyber security.
We need to get really, really,
really intentional about this.
And we are not at all.
I think you guys about
the XPRIZE Foundation?
Just a couple miles from here.
I'm working with them
to launch a $20 million
cyber XPRIZE for cyber security.
Whether it's a
10-year-old kid in Chennai
that's got the answer or an
80-year-old woman in Montreal,
I don't care.
We need to build more
resilient and redundant systems
to protect us.
The good news is, just to
put it all in perspective,
we can fix this.
Right, President Kennedy
said in the 1960s,
before this decade is out, we're
going to put a man on the moon.
We did that, with way worse tech
then we have available today.
If we could solve that
problem, surely we
could solve this cyber
security problem.
And we need to, because
technology is awesome.
And it's going to bring billions
of people out of poverty.
It's going to
radically extend life.
It's going to reduce
infant mortality.
It's going to educate millions
of people they never had access
to education previously.
But in order to achieve
that better future,
we're going to get
really intentional
about protecting against
these exponential undersides.
The downside of technology.
And that's what I'm hoping
to do with this book,
and I hope you guys will
join me in that fight.
Thank you so very much.
[APPLAUSE]